hey guys this is a quick public service
announcement before my interview with
david horowitz you know david horowitz
actually
said a couple lines that we are being
forced to censor
because of the youtube rules we have
never done something like this before
and as far as i know david horowitz is a
free citizen
in the free country of the united states
who is entitled to free speech
that being said i can't risk having this
channel deleted from youtube and that
basically is
what would happen if we went ahead and
aired it unedited
so you will hear some bleeps in this
interview if you would like to hear
what david horowitz a free man in a free
country actually said
you can check out the full video at
reubenreport.locals.com and
quick shout out to susan wojecki over at
youtube
if you look at the democrats agenda
it's not about getting rid of trump it's
not about winning an election
it's about establishing a one-party
state
stacked the supreme court that's to
abolish the independent judiciary
abolish the electoral college which was
designed to force
presidential candidates to compete in
battleground states where they didn't
have a majority
let's force them to compromise our whole
system
is built on compromise that that's why
we've only had one civil war
and no uh successful coup d'etats hats
the democrat program is a fascist
program
there is no nobody the only republicans
who were legitimate
are those uh you know like liz james
right they love they love liz cheney now
because she's a pet so
so you you lay all of this out in the
book
it's quite extraordinary actually and as
i said you've been right about a lot of
stuff way before
a lot of people so what do you think the
average conservative and i now use that
term
in a broad sense if you believe america
is good
you're a conservative as far as i'm
concerned what do you think the average
conservative can do to fight this
because it feels like the deck is
completely stacked against us
well republican conservatives have been
asleep for 50 years while the democrats
have
taken over our culture i wrote five
books on the universities that
one of them people paid a little
attention to
but the republican brand i organized
academic freedom campaigns
and i got no real support out of the
republican
party but a bomb between obama
and i call him the alzheimer puppet
uh invited
one of the nastiest human beings on the
planet i don't know how he gets his
reputation for being a nice guy
um they've begun to wake people up and
donald trump has given
our country and and patriots a great
gift
and that is he has created the first
mass
conservative movement in our history
when i came into the right in the mid
80s
40 years ago now looked around and said
where's the ground army all my
ex-comrades on the left are in awe
they had a hundred organizations or 200
to harass and threaten and defame
politicians until they got on there
into their program and corporations
are corporations involved you know
corporations are basically
cowards they don't want to lose
customers that's their
bottom line but if you harass them
enough
um they will respond and it's
interesting already the backlash has
caused them
uh disney just pulled back its
racist program um
i longed to see people get in the face
of teachers of principles of
superintendents of schools of school
boards
who are indoctrinating their children
and hate america
garbage and you know we're so backward i
was watching fox
and they're talking about the 1619
project
and they're talking about the 20 slaves
they weren't slaves i mean i've read
nell painter who is a black leftist
princeton historian on this subject
there were indentured servants and
slavery was actually
outlawed in virginia in 1619
and virginia was in america in 1619
it was a british colony and this is
supposed to be our founding
according to these liars and yet
you know if you look at fox they're not
saying they don't know the facts right
to be clear we were not a nation until
about 150 years later so the idea that
the nation was founded on something that
happened 150 years before when everyone
was dead
uh seemed a little odd exactly it's just
terrible
so so so what does the future is people
i want to see a sit-in
at the headquarters of twitter that
don't see their censorship
embarrassing them that's what's really
needed
and i i see the the stirrings of it all
over the place
there are people organized particularly
in the schools
and that that gives me hope yeah do you
think though that
since you brought up twitter that the
big tech part of this
is the part that makes the asymmetry so
out of whack it would be one thing if it
was slightly out of whack
but now the way we get information is so
tilted
that people can't coordinate properly
or can't even get the information
properly or agree on what's true
change is coming the one thing about
tech is it's always changing
um and what's it called sub stack
already
is a media outlet it has a lot of people
who
are second orders like you um
on it people with impeccable leftist
credentials who are
really upset about the canceled cults
and just the terms we use cancel
culture it's book burning it's what the
nazis did in the 30s
you can't burn just burn books today
because you've got a digital universe
that you can't
but that's what it is i would like to
see people
i mean i know that i'm not making myself
popular by referring to the bind
administration as fascist
but technically that's what it is and i
tell you
if we don't stop them they will put us
in re-education camps they've
already telegraphed that the
conservatives are
yahoo racists who have to be
reprogrammed
you think do we get to share a gulag as
the why i left the left guys that would
be nice
that's very probable right very probable
great
right look by solzhenitsyn's gulag
archipelago uh and that book really
moved me at the time
yeah well you know i toured with jordan
peterson and he often brought up the
gulag archipelago
for the same reason i always thank my
lucky stars for jordan peterson
otherwise i'd be feeling guilty about
all the things i wasn't writing
um so one part
i would like to mention is is the
chapter on
chapters on the blacklist
it's very very serious i'm not going to
name the outlet but i
i wrote this article um about how juan
radar should
join the fascist and slip the knife
between my ribs
i've i've got i've got the piece right
here yeah okay
i played i tried to place it
with a a concer a very prominent
conservative
media site but they they're also on
facebook
you know if you're a big media site you
got to be on all the platforms
and they said that we would facebook
would
shut them or just close it down if it
appeared there
people have to understand we are in the
early stages of a fascist state we do
not
america is no longer a free country uh
its freedom is hard won by courageous
people like yourself
who are willing to stand up and take the
slings and arrows
so what what do we do then i mean okay
so we can sit in a twitter i mean i know
you're you're a fighter you've been
doing this for a long time i mean what
what do we really do like where
so is trump the only thing that can save
us do we need the return of
trump to lead the republicans like it
ain't gonna be liz cheney here's what i
think about trump i
you know people are talking about ron
desantis who might
admire and in my blacklist story i tell
how they used
first you know they called me a
notorious racist then because he spoke
at my events they use that and when i
say day i'm
talking about the so-called liberal
media
new magazine washington post use that to
try to
taint him and and destroy him
and he has a delivery which a lot of
people think is
you know more user-friendly shall we say
than trump's
um and i hope he's on the ticket
actually
but the reason that i believe that trump
is bound to be the leader is
[Laughter]
he got 75 million votes despite
four years of unbelievable slander and
lies
directed him and no credit from what
what he had done
but i think ordinary americans patriotic
americans see
this guy and someone here he was
a billionaire living the life
and he put himself and his family
through
all this to save the country basically
and i mean those credentials are
golden you you really can't beat them
and i think his aggression is necessary
the reason the democrats hate him is
because he called them out
you know call them out as racist for
their control of the inner cities
um called about for their betrayal or
the kind
you know i will say as somebody who's
been in politics
50 60 years i had no idea
that they were selling us out in trade
deals the way they
i mean it's it's bush uh it's uh
you know bush clinton um obama
either they were too lazy to cut
decent deals for americans or they just
didn't care about
fleecing our country for chinese
communists their genocidal
dictators for crying out tears if you're
looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell